zum tagesgespräch bei phoenix begrüße
ich sehr herzlich jürgen hardt den
außenpolitischen sprecher der
unions-fraktion grüße sie in solingen
guten morgen herr kohle wird's ja fast
mit diesem sprichwort beschreiben alle
schäfchen sind wieder zu hause im stahl
und trocken ich mag es mal ein bisschen
sachlicher und sagt die soldatinnen und
soldaten sind wieder da sie sind nicht
verletzt und nicht noch gestorben auf
den letzten metern ist jetzt alles gut
natürlich nicht ich freue mich sehr dass
die soldatinnen und soldaten alle heim
nach hause gekommen sind meine gedanken
sind allerdings auch bei den angehörigen
der 13 gefallen den amerikanischen
soldatinnen und soldaten die uns bis in
den letzten tag hinein den rücken
freigehalten haben an den gates des
flughafens der einsatz war super
gefährlich aber unser material habt
funktioniert die soldaten haben gewusst
was sie zu tun haben sie hat die
bundeswehr ihre leistungsfähigkeit unter
beweis gestellt eine aufarbeitung des
gesamteinsatzes steht natürlich noch aus
deswegen halte ich jetzt verfrühte
schuldzuweisungen einzelne für nicht
richtig für mich dürfen wir bei aller
kritik an unserem eigenen verhalten am
verhalten der westlichen welt selbst
nicht auch aus dem auge verlieren dass
natürlich die afghanische regierung 20
jahre lang die chance hat in diesem land
etwas zustande zu bringen was nachhaltig
trägt sie hat viele milliarden hilfe
bekommen auch aus deutschland 15
milliarden hilfe über 20 jahre und sie
hat dieses diese chance nicht genutzt
insofern möchte ich ganz klar sagen die
hauptverantwortung für die situation in
afghanistan liegt tatsächlich auch bei
der regierung die möglicherweise
vielleicht sogar die soldaten
leichtfertig daran geändert hat sich den
taliban entgegenzustellen auch das find
ich muss gegenstand einer untersuchung
seien so gerne sein wir reden aber jetzt
eigentlich nicht über die anderen
sondern mal über uns auch wenn sie aus
dem politiker sind also das was graf
lambsdorff gerade sagte jetzt sind alle
da jetzt muss die aufarbeitung beginnen
jetzt müssen auch verantwortungen klar
benannt werden sie haben selber hat
gesagt
kritisch ran gehen wo es dann ihre
kritik oder wohin zieht sie meine kritik
liegt in erster linie daran dass ich
sage wie kann es sein dass alle
westlichen geheimdienste die ja nun
wirklich 20 jahre lang auch kontakte und
erfahrungen sammeln konnten in
afghanistan so schieflagen mit ihrer
einschätzung was die situation in kabul
und die haltung der regierung angeht das
ist etwas was ich mir nicht erklären
kann der glaube ich dass die
verantwortung nicht allein bei den
deutschen diensten liegt das ist ja um
den globus herum diese fehleinschätzung
gewesen aber wir müssen uns schon die
frage stellen wie es dazu kommen kann
das zweite ist haben wir im zusammenhang
mit der rückführung von ortskräfte
rechtzeitig gehandelt aus heutiger sicht
wird man sagen wenn man es gewusst hätte
wie es tatsächlich vor 14 tagen gegangen
ist in kabul hätte man früher mehr
zurückführen müssen andererseits wenn
wir bereits im mai juni juli angefangen
hätten in tausender zahlen beschäftigte
des staates beschäftigte der bundeswehr
der zivilen hilfsorganisationen aus
afghanistan raus zu holen dann wäre im
land möglicherweise panik ausgebrochen
so nach dem motto was droht wenn der
westen abzieht das war eine schwierige
gratwanderung die bundeskanzlerin hat
der bundestag letzte woche dargestellt
und es wird abzuprüfen sein und
abzuwägen sein ob man möglicherweise
besser eine andere entscheidung
getroffen hätte aber ein vierteiliges
voreiliges urteil darüber glaube ich ist
unangemessen aber ist angemessen darüber
nachzudenken was dann gewesen wäre wenn
die botschafts mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter vielleicht doch zwei tage
eher hätten ausreisen können
die botschaftsmitarbeiterin die
deutschen die tatsächlich hat
deutschland zurückgeführt wurden sind
gemeinsam mit den botschaftsangehörigen
vieler anderer botschaften über die
amerikanische botschaft aus kabul
ausgeflogen worden das ist die position
die sie vorgesehen war es hat die
entscheidung der bundesregierung gegeben
die botschaft so lange aufzuhalten wie
andere botschaften auch dort ihre arbeit
versehen haben war dann eben gemeinsam
mit anderen raus zu gehen also
spezieller in diesem punkt habe ich nur
die aussage des außenministers und ich
habe keine gegenteilige erkenntnis das
wird natürlich auch in der neuen
legislaturperiode gegenstand der
parlamentarischen debatte sein dann
erklärt sich mir gar nicht die kritik am
außenminister können sie da noch
verstehen
ich werfe dem außenminister konkret vor
dass er genau wie viele andere die
situation nicht so vorhergesehen hat ich
hätte mir im übrigen der wunsch dass er
vielleicht schon etwas früher auf reisen
gegangen wäre ich finde es sehr gut dass
er jetzt ganz konkret in der region aber
auch mit den taliban gespräche führt mit
den zielen die wir verfolgen nämlich
dass die flüchtlinge die über die grenze
von afghanistan in andere länder kommen
entsprechend gut wahrgenommen werden und
dass wir mit den taliban möglicherweise
doch eine vereinbarung des westens
treffen können wie wir bestimmte
personen auch aus dem land herausholen
können in zukunft und ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir auch eine basis finden
mit den taliban die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit fortzusetzen
was ja unsererseits an die bedingung
geknüpft sein muss dass menschenrechte
im land geachtet werden das wäre ein
großer schritt nach vorne wenn die
taliban eben nicht anknüpfen würden an
das was ende der 90er jahre war sondern
wenn sie einen sinneswandel bei sicher
bei führen das ist eine große hoffnung
der hebel ist unsere wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklungshilfe und
das muss heiko maas ganz klar sagen es
gibt wird keine unterstützung für
afghanistan und die taliban führung in
afghanistan geben wenn sie nicht bereit
das menschenrechte zu achten und uns im
bereich der frage der der der
reisemöglichkeiten etwa entsprechend
entgegenkommt wir haben wir müssen ja
auch irgendwie gucken wie wir als westen
nach anderen gegenübertreten können wie
zum beispiel russland und china als
großmächte wenn wir uns doch eigentlich
nicht so richtig gerade hervorgetan
haben und eigentlich ziemlich schwach
aussehen im westen oder
ich fürchte dass wir tatsächlich erleben
werden dass russland und china dieses
machtvakuum nutzen werden dass sie
möglicherweise wenn die taliban wieder
unter bedrängnis kommen durch
terroristen wir sehen ja jetzt bereits
an den bombenanschlägen dass es
keineswegs so ist dass die taliban das
land wirklich kontrollieren sondern
terrorismus macht sich möglicherweise
wieder breit dass china und russland
vielleicht helfen könnten an der seite
der taliban
ich glaube das müssen wir
mit der mit der nötigen ehrlichkeit auch
im besten betrachten wir haben gemeinsam
mit der mit der nato und mit vielen
anderen nationen 20 jahre lang versucht
diesen stabilen zustand in afghanistan
zu erzeugen wir können das andere nicht
vorwerfen wenn sie jetzt auch ihren
versuch starten ich glaube dass das
natürlich idealerweise durch einstimmige
voten des un-sicherheitsrates auch in
einer international völkerrechtlichen
rahmen gebracht wird in dem sich das
dann vollzieht aber ich bin weit davon
entfernt jetzt china oder russland zu
kritisieren wenn sie versuchen auch auf
die befriedung des landes einzuwirken am
besten tun wir das allerdings zusammen
im un sicherheitsrat er hat schauen wir
noch ein bisschen in die zukunft schauen
wir auf marley und ich sage nur
stichwort afghanistan 2.0
fragezeichen
das ist eine der zentralen fragen die
uns alle beschäftigt
fraktionsübergreifende deutschen
bundestag weil sie in mali ja auch
einerseits terrorismusbekämpfung machen
was auch leidlich funktioniert genau wie
das in afghanistan der fall war zum
anderen aber versuchen selbsttragende
strukturen in denen in dem land mali und
auch in anderen staaten der sahelzone zu
erreichen die in der lage sind solche
terroristischen gefahren auf dauer aus
eigener kraft zu verhindern und wenn ich
das mit afghanistan vergleicht so gibt
es in mali meine sachen es einen
entscheidenden unterschied und wir
müssen prüfen ob das tatsächlich auch in
der sache einen unterschied macht wir
haben in mali verbündete in afrika die
afrikanische union die ecowas also die
wirtschaftsorganisation westafrikas
andere afrika afrikanische strukturen
wollen dieses thema gemeinsam mit uns
angehen und es ist eben nicht so wie in
afghanistan dass wir letztlich ein
taliban freundliches pakistan
nicht erreichbares und nicht zu
konsultationen in der lage sind diesen
iran haben und daneben zentralasiatische
republiken die vergleichsweise schwach
sind sondern wir haben um molly herum in
der region staaten die mit uns gemeinsam
dieses ziel verfolgen und eigentlich
müssten diese staaten insgesamt in die
lage versetzt werden solche
terroristischen geschichten wie wir sie
in mali erleben vor allem in mali aber
auch in china phase aus eigener kraft
entsprechend in den griff zu kriegen und
wir sollten sie dabei ertüchtigen das
ist eine wie ich finde doch schon
deutlich andere situation als in
afghanistan ob das bereits ausreicht ich
glaube auf jeden fall dass wir die mal
die strategie diesem blick überprüfen
müssen wir sollten aus alldem gelernt
haben was wir in den letzten tagen
erlebt haben jürgen hardt ich sage ihnen
ganz herzlich danke schön nach so denn